Address translation process.
And the reason that translation has to
happen is because process thinks it has
this big address space, contiguous
going from zero through some x.
And then we said,
well the physical memory, one process
may not have all of it at the same time.
Or physical memory maybe much smaller
than the address space size itself.
So logical address or
virtual address is actually going to be
different from the physical
address that we're talking about.
So this is actually, if you think about
it, this is a logical address here.
And addresses that we have here
are going to be addresses into physical
memory.
Right, that's your real memory
that you have in the system.
So what we're going to do is, we're
saying, well, this part is going here.
That part is going here.
So, maybe 1 goes at the top here,
maybe 3 goes down here,
and things like that.
We said we have to take data and
code that is in the address space,
and we have to place that
into physical memory, okay?
The way we sort of do that is,
we don't want to do it for each byte or
each word, because we'll have to
keep track of what's going where.
Okay, so one way to scale that
process is is that we divide this
address space and
the memory into some size chunks.
Okay, so if we do paging,
it's divided into what's called pages.
A page typically may be 4 kilobytes,
for example, 4K size.
So we would say, well, the address
space really is a page number and
displacement within that page.
So this is page 0, and if your location
10, then it's page 0, 10, okay.
So 0 is the page, and
10 is displacement within that page.
If your address happens to be let's say,
4K plus 3,
then it's going to do a second page
because second page starts at 4K.
First 0 through 4K minus goes in first
page, and then the second one starts.
So then we'll say it's page 2 and maybe
displacement 5 or 2 or whatever it is.
So the logical address you can
think of that as a page number and
a displacement.
Essentially a page table says,
this, it is a mapping isn't it?
So it says this logical page is
currently stored in this physical page.
Okay, so if I want to think about it,
a page table, essentially,
a page table we have all these entries.
And it's logical base 0, 1, 2.
We're saying this may be a 3.
This may be at 5.
This may be at 8.
And maybe 3 is currently not loaded.
Virtual memory, not everything
is in memory at the same time.
So this a page table that actually
we build, and the operating
system is responsible for actually
building this and protecting this.
Remember, at this point, sort of
a flow that we should understand,
it's really important.
A process, maybe executing in
user space, generates an address,
okay, saying I need to
fetch the next instruction.
That's where my instruction point or
program counter points, or an operand,
or whatever it is.
And I need to access
this memory location.
It sort of starts with
a logical address.
The system now says,
well, where exactly is this
information that the process needs?
We need to locate the physical address
to which this logical address maps.
For that, what I'm going to do
is I'm going to take the logical
address page #, and
I'm going to look up this page table.
So this address translation requires
that you access this page table,
and there are ways to speed
this whole process up.
So it's saying if page number is 3,
or let's say the page number is 2,
then I go down here and I say oh,
it's in physical memory page 8.
So the address that we have,
if it's 3 and some displacement,
d, could translate to 8 and
the same displacement.
So it's say memory page 8 and go dig
down d locations or d bytes in that.
This is what is called
the address translation process.
So an important observation here is
that we can only access physical memory
that is reachable through this page
table that we have for this process.
I should say page table a lot
more complicated than multilevel,
things like that.
But let's just sort of stay with this
basic idea of how they help us get
this isolation which is important to us
because the process has
to start with an address.
Address has to be translated.
Translation is only possible
through this page table.
So whatever the page table points
to is all a process can access.
Another observation here that we
should be clearly understanding,
is, the page tables have to be
maintained by the operating system.
They have to be managed by
their trusted computing base
because whatever goes into the page
table, we can access that.
So the operating system should make sure
that whatever goes in the page table of
a particular process is only memory
that belongs to that process.
So, that's the address translation.
It gives you a little bit
more information about
what part of memory a given
process is able to access,
and it relates to this isolation
thing that we've been talking about.